Based on the fact that you're all in
this class, I'm reasonably sure you're
all familiar with online learning,
because you're all doing it right now.
When most people think
about online learning,
I think what they think about though,
are MOOCs, massive open online courses.
MOOCs got very big for a few years
there, and they're still very big.
And so we're actually going to have
an entire separate section on MOOCs.
But online learning is more
than just MOOCs nowadays.
You're all doing online learning,
but you're not in the MOOC.
This class is not massive, it's large,
but it's not massive, and it's not open.
You all applied to this program and
you were accepted, so
it's neither massive nor open.
But it's still an online course.
What we do here at Udacity
nowadays is similar.
We no longer do massive
open online courses.
We do smaller, very large, but
still smaller than massive open online
courses, programs that
are somewhat more gated,
that have a cost associated with them
and have a credential at the end.
And I think programs like
Udacity's Nano degrees and
the Georgia Tech OMS CS program are
really the future of online learning,
these more closed and
more gated experiences.
So what we're going to talk about here,
is the different ways that online
learning can be done
separate from MOOCs.
So what are the experiences we can
have in online learning that would be
difficult or
impossible to have on campus?
Are there things we can do here that
are actually even better than we can do
on campus?
And there's certain things we can do
in person that we can't do online, but
how do we make up for them?
How do we create an equivalent
experience in this online environment
to what you might get on campus?